ready
i like world creation i think that's
world building it's really interesting
but the idea was making a family movie
that has a dark quirky edge to it
[Music]
here we go
miguel's vision is extremely sharp and
not intimidated by tough themes
difficult shooting schedules or
incredibly complicated effects shots
the project originated with miguel
sapochnick the director who had
developed it with the writers ivor
powell and craig luck craig actually
started it as a short story and they
partnered to write the script and
brought it to miguel
miguel is a director is an incredible
visionary because his
visual style fit in epic movies so
perfectly
when the movie begins it's 10 years
after this post-apocalyptic event and we
wanted to try and do something that was
literally focused on the relationship
between the characters
finch is an engineer and a computer
scientist and a developer of software
and as far as his part of the world he's
the only guy left
we're in a facility that operated at the
soundstage
but when finch has to escape from this
part of the world then everything else
that was outdoors we shot literally you
know outdoors
so he has this escape vehicle that he's
slowly been putting together and they
gotta pile into the family rv and take
off when we're trying to create a world
for these characters to exist and the rv
is a central character we spend maybe 50
60 percent of the film in a road trip
it's something it can live it has a
little kitchen and if i jack it up and i
put it on big old monster truck wheels
then i'm going to roll over any obstacle
i can
we had firemen suits and hazmat suits
and all different kinds of outdoor boots
and gloves and helmets and goggles and
it was cool to see tom think about what
would finch do with this stuff i had a
lot of costume fittings and meetings i
was very glad to be in my ultraviolet
protection suit there because everybody
else was just wind burned and i kind of
got to sit inside with an
air-conditioned helmet even when we're
outside when tom puts it on the almost
instantly feels iconic
get your elbows off the table get your
elbows off the kick sheamus who is the
acting dog that plays good year i mean
he's just an award winner as far as
charm goes
letting him do his own thing gets you
far more interesting stuff and then he
also has these great eyebrows
so anytime he kind of raises his eyebrow
in one direction it feels like a really
big thing we hired the best dog trainer
in the business in mark forbes and we
basically auditioned a bunch of dogs we
narrowed it down to two of our favorite
dogs and then we had tom hanks come in
and help us decide on sheamus sheamus
had verve he carried with him a type of
mysterious gravitas the projection i
think that comes along with a man and
his dog in this case is that the
audience begins to supply sheamus's
dialogue all right you're next
come here dog breath
they begin to understand what in this
case goodyear is thinking and what his
responses are to it oh
where's your paw
is it here
i'd like to think that as the actor i
bring
a number of goods to the mix
caleb as jeff brings a substantial
amount of elements to it that i cannot
provide and what was missing from the
movie from the two of us
sheamus provided
now it is a classic
triangle of life forms
it is the canine life form the human
life form and caleb landry jones as jeff
this robot this companion actually
would you like me to drive oh you just
learned how to walk on this movie we
were introduced to the project by tom
meyer the production designer who came
up with the designs for dewey and for
jeff dewey is a much simpler character
jeff is really finch
and he learns throughout the whole movie
how to become a man whereas dewey will
always only ever be this character that
can't really emote
jeff was really a great design and
something that was grounded in the real
world so his head is the top of a
welding gas tank a lot of his body parts
from finding things you would use in a
real workshop
jeff is six foot six inches tall
so we created stilts so the interesting
part of the performance of jeff is the
gates of the walk
we got so used to working with caleb and
we used mocap a moving suit that
recalled his movements
that's been a really interesting and
experimental thing
one of the other things that miguel told
me when we were designing jeff is can
opener right in his chest right where
his heart needs to be
his heart
is the well-being of the dog these
robots take on a certain humanity that
other robots in the past certainly don't
seem to have had and i think you get
that from the performance of puppeteers
caleb and the cg jeff
tornado
[Music]
it was so windy that day that we had
wind machines that lay unused
because we had about a 50 to 60 mile an
hour wind that was blowing all the sand
the great thing about cgi now is you can
do anything and i didn't remember caleb
in costume i was just seeing jeff as
jeff get back in here
what we have to create with visual
effects is the artificial intelligence
robot based on caleb's performance and
kind of give the world a taste of the
promise of what future technology is but
then have this really dark world that's
very hard to survive in
[Music]
the beautiful thing that the film does
that i think the audience recognizes is
that
it is not human to be alone
it is not human to be a solo being
we must have company
because in company we find companionship
we find love
that's the high country man
when you can capture that on film
[Music]
you